une bouteille en verre utilisé puis
rendue contre quelques francs puis
réutilisé et ce jusqu'à 40 fois c'était
le principe du verre consigné mais avec
les années 60 début d'une nouvelle ère
celle qui prête à consommer et à jeter
expéditif et elle me repose l'emballage
perdu gagne les ménages en verre ou en
plastique
il a conquis les fabricants de
bouteilles je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse imaginer de revenir tous azimuts
à la consignation la consigne snobé par
le progrès et par les consommateurs
moi je suis folle vers perdu est-ce que
je suis une femme dit sans vagues et
j'ai pas le temps vers perdu lui est
recyclé donc récupérer broyer fondu pour
devenir une nouvelle bouteille le procès
des quinze fois plus énergivore que la
consigne le nettoyage qui va avec
en 1981 l'oscd eux préconisent donc un
retour à la consigne d'autant qu'il
générerait des emplois mais rien n'y
fait en 1982 une journaliste et une
potentielle explication dans cette
affaire de puissants intérêts sont en
jeu qui ont réussi jusqu'à présent à
faire reculer les pouvoirs publics mais
cool de pression en ce moment-même
agissent sur la communauté européenne
pour imposer leur politique du
gaspillage et empêcher tout retour n'est
moins donner à la possible
les consommateurs européens doivent le
savoir sans compter que pour les
industriels l'emballage perdu c'est tout
bénef
quand ils vous vendent du vin de l'eau
minérale la bière ils vont non seulement
ce produit mais ils vendent également un
emballage à l'emballage qui coûte cher
et que l'on jette à chaque fois et très
souvent d'ailleurs les fabricants de ces
produits sont également des fabricants
d'emballages c'est-à-dire de bouteilles
quasiment plus pratiqués la consigne est
officiellement abandonné en 1999 au
profit de l'emballage à usage unique une
région fait néanmoins de la résistance
dans les grandes surfaces comme dans les
petits commerces c'est l'alsace à un
moment où on parle beaucoup
d'environnements d'écologie je pense que
quelque part reprendre le le vert le
consigne est passé faire partie de cette
mouvance déchets option consignes ces
dix dernières années certains commerces
et associations ont remis la pratique au
goût du jour
[Musique]